[Music]
hello everybody R what's up wait a
minute three girls one wife something is
missing this guy there's my
boys I know you love your D go on say it
d d yeah yes of course he loves you he
just he just doesn't show it on his face
or with his body language right FW
Junior come
on gr I need a word with you your
family's lives are at stake
what maximal has escaped from prison I'm
coming for my revenge
group we have to get to the safe house
it has
a I love this place
look here she the most important part of
a heist is being aware of potential
dangers
she I Tred
myself oh here
she watch out watch out watch out watch
out
no
what
intrud
thanks
Ron fire in
the